[Music]
reports that Bam Margera was
hospitalized in December didn't explain
just how close to death the Jackass star
came but now the Daredevil is giving the
full story in his own words the usher in
the New Millennium in Grand fashion MTV
debuted a show on October 2000 that
remains as culturally relevant and
hilarious as ever jackass if you're
somehow unfamiliar with the series it
featured a group of stuntmen and old
friends doing pranks to each other and
attempting wild stunts to say it became
a hit would be an understatement some of
the original stars of the show including
Johnny Knoxville and Steve-O have stayed
in the public eye and kept the legacy of
Jackass alive but that hasn't been true
for the entirety of the original crew
for one there's Bam Margera who has
lived a roller coaster life since a now
iconic MTV series first game prominence
Margera has found himself in some
terrifying and rather unsavory
situations including drama with some of
his jackass co-stars Knoxville among
them nevertheless he's managed to power
through and lived to tell his story all
these years later but Margera revealed
he recently came very close to death on
January 5th 2023 Margera stopped by the
Stevo's Wild Ride podcast to commemorate
the end of his conservatorship before he
could get to that though he had a scary
story from the previous month to share
with listeners right out of the gate he
shared the news of his own death it
basically was pronounced dead on Elvis's
birthday December 8th Margera didn't
realize it but he'd been dealing with an
extreme case of covet 19. he added that
his body started shutting down and he
had four seizures Each of which lasted
between 10 and 20 minutes the fourth was
so bad that he says he nearly bit off
his tongue Margera's tongue became
swollen and began bleeding Margera then
swallowed the blood which in turn
resulted in him Contracting pneumonia of
course yeah it's on his way to the
hospital he went into a pith seizure
with his swollen tongue he couldn't
breathe when he finally came two in the
hospital he thought he'd only been there
for a few hours it couldn't have been
more wrong shortly after waking up he
remembered being told I was like dude
you've been here for nearly a week we
tried to take the tube out and you
weren't breathing on your own thankfully
eight days after being admitted to the
hospital Margera made a full recovery
and was released news outlets picked up
on the story almost immediately Stevo
mentioned that after hearing about it on
the news and seeing Margera on a
ventilator he assumed the worst was
right around the corner I'm just
thinking oh my God like this is it while
marjero was in the hospital Stevo joked
that if his friend didn't make it
through that would throw a serious
wrench into his tour plans some fans
loved the jackass style Gallows humor
others didn't Stevo made sure to clarify
that Margera's recovery was the top
priority Margera chined in with a laugh
and compared his newly raspy voice
thanks to the breathing tube to that of
Steve-O Margera doesn't remember much of
what happened to him prior to waking up
in the hospital saying that he
essentially blacked out until he opened
his eyes in the hospital bed it's safe
to assume he didn't miss a whole lot
throughout his lengthy Hospital stay as
if the past few years haven't shown it
already covid-19 is no joke and is more
than capable of killing at a moment's
notice it's good to hear that Bam
Margera was able to recover from the
deadly disease
[Music]